an electorate of over 400 million had
its say after counting began it soon
became clear that voters had spoken out
against the solid center of European
politics
we are facing a shrinking center of the
European Parliament the center of those
parties who believe in the future of
Europe ovens two drinks in Europe who
wants to have an ambitious approach for
the future of Europe that is what we are
facing a shrinking center that trend
gave German mainstream parties their
worst ever
EU election results while boosting the
European far-right in France marine
lepen again beat the French president's
party Hungary's Victor Orbin spelled it
out
I think the migration issue by itself
and the reaction of the people on it
will reorganize the political spectrum
with the European Union so the
traditional party families will not play
the same role in the future as they have
done in the recent years socialists and
Democrats party list candidate Franz
Timmerman called for humility as his
party lost 35 seats and stressed the
need for cooperation among the so-called
progressives I will repeat my
proposition to work with other
progressive parties in this Parliament
to try and build a program that
addresses the aspirations the dreams and
also sometimes the fears of our fellow
Europeans those progressive parties
include the jubilant greens resurgent in
Germany and set to become a big hitter
in the European Parliament the liberal
Alda group also made significant gains
their candidate mark Petrova styie
now has designed on becoming European
Commission president from living in
Europe thank you
the monopoly of power is broken and this
is of course why we can do something
else and I very much appreciated it was
my colleague Franz similar and just said
that a coalition can be built of those
who wants to do something
yellow vests protesters in Brussels on
Sunday they say the EU is undemocratic
everybody wants to change Europe the
fight over which way will be played out
in the parliament and on the streets
well as the results come in from the 28
member countries of the EU the trends
are getting clearer right now here are
some of the projections for seats in the
next European Parliament we see that
surge for the greens they look likely to
take 69 seats in the new parliament and
the liberal the pro-business Aldi group
they'll be taking 102 seats now despite
its heavy losses the centre-right
European People's Party is still the
single biggest group with 167th season
if we look at the two right-wing
populist blocks here on the right of our
graphic will you see them at 47 seats
and 73 seats respectively putting them
at 120 together ok let's go live now to
Brussels get some reaction from DWS teri
Schultz standing by for us Harry for the
first time now in 40 years the big
centrist party is no longer commanding a
majority in the parliament now how is
that going to change how business is
done in Brussels well it simply can't be
business as usual here anymore Brian
because the two largest political groups
who are used to being able to get their
way by sheer numbers simply can't do
that anymore and that's why you see
Montford weber and friends timmermans
saying let's work together let's you
know find common policies let's let's
reach out and work on on programmes
together because they simply won't have
any choice anymore and it's not only
that people didn't vote for these
parties is that they turned out in such
huge numbers record numbers in some
countries more than 50% of eligible
voters reversed the trend of apathy in
European Parliament elections and went
out to cast their votes so this simply
can't be ignored and it that has not
been lost on on the largest political
parties okay let's look at the
beneficiaries of that big turnout
they've been the Greens on the left and
and the nationalist parties on the
far-right will they now though have the
weight to make their policy wishes
I have some kind of for some kind of
impact in Parliament in Brussels they
will simply because of that
fragmentation that we've been speaking
about they don't have to be the largest
groups to have a weight because they're
going to have to be brought in on
decisions with the largest political
groups the European People's Party and
the Socialists and Democrats who can no
longer do it alone so these two largest
political groups will have to make
common cause with the greens and the
Liberals if they don't want to have to
work with the populist parties the
anti-eu parties the euro skeptics and
Manfred Weber has come out very clearly
last night and and said that he will not
work with any party that doesn't have
the European spirit at heart that
doesn't believe in the European project
so at least at this point he is very
much trying to downplay Euroskeptics
hopes of being kingmakers Brian okay
well we'll see if that works out I'm
moving forward teri Schultz thanks very
much for that from Brussels
okay let's cross now to London where our
correspondent Alex Boris whiting
standing by and Federica Basho's with us
in Milan good morning to both of you
Nigel frost his party the brexit party
trouncing the main parties in britain
the far-right party of matteo salvini
also topping the poll in italy let's
start with you Alex Britain's
conservatives and Labour's you know
waking up to a very difficult morning
what kind of impact as ferocious brexit
party had today where you are in London
an absolutely huge impact Brian
particularly on the Conservative Party
the Conservative Party the ruling party
didn't come first second third fourth
but fifth agony for them and losing many
many of their votes to that brexit party
Nigel Ferraris party which only
officially set up six weeks ago so it
really is extraordinary he got something
like 28 seats 32 percent of the votes
whereas the Conservatives at the moment
have only got 3 seats so it just shows
what he has done and there is huge
reaction within the Conservative Party
from the likes of Boris Johnson who is
one of the potentials to be the next
Conservative Party leader and Prime
Minister saying we've got to get brexit
sorted he's already advocated with a
deal with the EU or with not a deal
that's how far he is prepared to push it
but it's not just the Conservative Party
also the Labour Party now they had done
very badly - they've come third they
have lost many votes to the Liberal
Democrats and that is because many
labour voters didn't vote labour this
time they voted Lib Dem because the Lib
Dems want to remain in the EU and this
all came down to breakfast yet again the
UK completely divided over this issue of
brexit okay the UK might be divided but
Nigel frosh has been very clear about
what he wants to see happen as a result
of this vote let's take a listen to that
we've got a deadline of the 31st of
October all right that is the date upon
which were supposed to leave the
European Union that's in five months
time and what we're saying is we've got
a mandate now we demand to be part of
that negotiating team to get this
country ready to leave whatever the
circumstance okay what does that mean
well we see now brexit an inevitable
brexit in october nothing with brexit is
inevitable and that has to be
highlighted we know that the next
deadline for the UK to leave the EU is
the 31st of October and the
Conservatives are really going to push
for that trying to get a deal across and
we may well see
possibly the next conservative leader
bringing onboard nigel farage in some
way to try to bring back those voters
because they have hemorrhaged so many to
the brexit party however with the Labour
Party now pretty much it's pretty clear
that because they have tried to right
sit on the fence over brexit they've got
to make a decision and many of their
voters and their members do not like
brexit if they are going to start saying
look there has to be a second referendum
we are campaigning for a second
referendum and we are campaigning to
remain then it means that the the boats
and the the numbers in Parliament are
still going to be very difficult and
therefore we are still in a position
that we don't know what will happen with
brexit there is no clear way forward
okay let's look at the way forward for
the growing nationalist grouping in the
parliament let's go to federico Biagio
and milan Federica matteo salvini is
aiming to build a pan Nationals bloc in
the EU Parliament here's what he had to
say after the results in Italy were
announced now we are the first party in
the north and the south we got above 50%
in so many cities and we also came first
in many cities in the center we will go
to work with even more energy passion
and dedication the league is not only
the first party in Italy marine lepen is
also the top European Party in France
and Nigel Farage's party is the top
party in Britain so Italy France and
England it is a sign of a Europe which
is changing a Europe that is changing
Federico what's the sense where you are
has Salvi knees victory in Italy meant
that Italy will now be the country that
will be forming the new pan nationalist
front in the European Parliament
well Brian that's certainly what Marcel
salvini really would like this big win
for him is a win for nationalism at the
European level and for his project of
building upon European alliance of
nationalist parties in the new European
peril
however there are still some questions
concerning this alliance and how much it
will really be able to matter in the new
European Parliament the first question
regards how these these countries these
parties that have committed to this
alliance are going to be able to work
together to show a united front when
they have a conflicting interests in
some respects for they have they have
different affiliations towards Russia
for example so how are they gonna be
able to work together and that the other
question is whether there are other
bigger groups more traditional groups
inside the European Parliament are going
to consider building maybe deals with
Salvi knees alliance this is something
that he certainly would like that would
enable him to be part of the big games
and not just be and marginalized as an
opposition voice okay that is his big
goal isn't it
mainstreaming the nationalist message in
the European Parliament but but what
about nationally he's made some real
gains compared to the lastly European
election how is this vote going to
affect national politics in Italy
absolutely I mean this has had it's
going to have a big impact at the
national level necessarily and there has
been a huge dramatic shift in power here
in Italy and that's not only because of
material salvini is a victory but also
because the senior coalition partner in
Italy's coalition government at the
populous five star movement and they
have scored a huge loss they've only did
not even been able to place themselves
second but a third with a 17% of vote
that is almost a half of what they got
in last year's general election so their
support really has gone down massively
and there has been speculation here in
Italy in the last weeks whether a big
win for the lead would mean that much
vini and his party would be tempted to
pull the plug on the current coalition
government on the current coalition with
the five stars which has been extremely
difficult since the start since last
year
however ANATEL salvini has rejected this
speculation for now he said again last
night when he was here at the
headquarters in Milan that he still
considers the five stars as as an ally
as a as a friend and that he is he's
willing to keep working with with the
party but we'll have to see what happens
in the next day's ok we'll get more word
from Milan though on that in the days
ahead Alex I'd like to wrap up this with
a question to you about Nigel Faraj
demanding a seat at the brexit talks as
a result of his win in the European
parliamentary elections is he going to
get that is he going to be sitting down
now and helping determine where Britain
goes in the brexit process
well you certainly can't rule that out
and it does depend on who becomes the
next leader of the Conservative Party in
therefore the next prime minister I
don't think it would be impossible for
example if it was Boris Johnson for him
to decide that he does in some way have
to bring Nigel Farage in to help because
of them hemorrhaging so many votes to
the brexit party the problem is though
that he has to be careful not to
alienate those many other people
including conservative party members who
don't want a hard brexit or no deal
brexit and that's where you could see
other candidates for example Michael
Gove trying to be more careful about
that but nobody can pretend that Nigel
Farage is not now a dominant force in
British politics and particularly over
brexit brexit has come about because of
this one man he has been pushing for
this for many years it hasn't yet
happened it should have happened on the
29th of March and so he is back and that
is what he is trying to do and he's now
proving to all the to the so-called
elites to all the political parties
that a huge majority of people in the UK
want brexit to happen and want to leave
and he cannot be ignored and it would be
dangerous particularly for the
Conservatives to ignore him okay and
we'll see where he takes this from here
Alex thanks for that and thanks to
Federica
Biagio and malong as well well here in
Germany Angela Merkel's governing
coalition is assessing the damage after
her conservatives and their Social
Democrat partners in the coalition were
dealt their worst score ever in European
election history now the biggest winners
were the German Greens they doubled
their showing now they're now Germany's
second strongest party in Brussels the
far-right populist AFD also gaining
ground especially among Eastern German
voters sometimes reactions speak louder
than words the German greens ecstatic as
they watch their vote surge this triumph
built off the back of young voters and
the climate emergency a warning shot to
the country's government the signal
today is that the German government has
been voted down as a result of its
hesitation on climate protection and its
failure to unify Europe we are fighting
for European solidarity and strong
climate protection at the CDU party be
watched on and read not exactly drowning
their sorrows but these results down 7%
make for sobering reading as the party
grappled with the country's shifting
demographics
some iron retards offered us certainly
we have not been dynamic enough in
government and we fail to give
convincing answers that voters across
Germany have expected of us in
Deutschland
across town at their government
coalition partners the SPD it was a
picture of full-frontal despair they saw
almost half their vote disappear 27
percent to 15 the party's leadership
pleaded for members not to lose the
faith I would like to ask all our SPD
members and supporters to take heart and
to look confidently to the future even
if today's results are painful they show
us that we have a lot to do for the
far-right EFD it was more a night of
schadenfreude er
than success the biggest cheer for the
SPD and CDU losses they had threatened
an insurgency but in the end mustered
10% the disappointment hard to hide we
are going to Brussels to repair the EU
to reduce the EU to its core work that
is why we have been elected and that is
what we are going to do in Brussels
these may have been European elections
but their results may well shake up
domestic politics too
well just how much is the question to
talk about that I'm joined by DW
political correspondent Simon Young
assignment the traditional parties in
here in Germany take taking a real
drubbing you know what does it look like
well how's this going to impact domestic
politics well I think it's unleashing
renewed concerns about whether the
parties are set properly to appeal to
the electorate I mean this is an
extraordinarily bad result for the two
government parties conservatives and
Social Democrats between them they've
lost 20% of the national support
compared with the European election last
time around and that's a pretty massive
loss on both sides particularly the
Social Democrats they've done terribly
badly you know they for instance were in
power in in the regional state of Bremen
which has also been held yesterday an
election there for 73 years and they've
lost control of that state that just
shows you I mean that's reflected
certainly the CDU yeah okay when we look
at the Greens a spectacular result
really better than even even they
expected we're gonna have a lot more of
that about that today from the Green
Party headquarters now why have they
been so successful especially in getting
out the youth vote yeah I think they
have cause of the environment and
climate protection have been core issues
of theirs for decades that is a topic
that has come back lately particularly
with these protests such as Friday's for
future that we've seen that have
attracted a lot of young people and the
fact that many young people in
particular are galvanized by the idea of
Europe and they have turned out to vote
in this election has meant good things
for the Greens they say they're going to
ride this result here and it's there's
there's a pretty strong result for the
Greens in many other European countries
as well they're going to use their
influence in the European Parliament
they say they're going to try and bring
about for instance a a change in
European agriculture policy they want to
see smaller farms and less sort of big
Agra
business that kind of thing but of
course its climate change that's the the
real core issue for them and we're going
to be hearing from the Greens very
shortly because they'll be holding a
press conference you want and and there
could be some you know very
controversial issues that they'll be
confronting like the carbon tax for
example which might not be a winner with
voters we'll see about that
let's talk about the far-right AFD
alternative for Germany they were
polling as high as 14% they came in on
11% their leader
Alexander gallon not not sounding
particularly thrilled about the raziel
result are they losing momentum well I
mean against that prediction they have
lost some momentum that's true but I
think that was quite a high prediction I
think that I mean they're a Euroskeptic
party but they haven't put forward a
very clear message and so perhaps that
has cost them some votes for instance
there are some within the AFD who
support so-called exit the idea that
ultimately Germany should you know
either get the changes at once or leave
the European Union not a popular
position it's not a popular position and
not even within the AFD itself have all
members supported it so there been
problems there there's also been some
funding scandals that the party has been
touched by and also the idea that they
haven't put enough space between
themselves and the Austrian far-right
who've had this big scandal in the last
week or so with you know the deputy
Chancellor there being sort of videoed
offering support to Russian supporters
so these are if you like it sort of dark
clouds around the AFD that I think
possibly have driven away some voters
but we should point out they've done
incredibly well in eastern Germany
coming top in at least a couple of the
regional states and that's a big threat
to to the government as well the high
voter turnout definitely benefited them
at least to a certain degree as it did
the Greens
I'm a voter turnout for European
elections has been traditionally when he
compared to other EU countries strong
here in Germany this time around what
was driving it was a climate change was
at migration what were the
big issues I think I think those two
were the were the big issues I think
voter turnout might have been boosted
too by the fact that we had that vote in
the state of Bremen so you've got people
going to the polls anyway there they're
also local municipal elections in at
least 10 states as well so you know
people have that extra reason to get out
and vote that shows that it's probably a
good idea to bring elections together on
the same day as much as possible and
this this jump from 48 percent turnout
was what we had last time now it's
something over 60% so there's a big
there's a that's a big turnout for a
European election shows shows that I
think people are interested in these
European issues as you say the climate
migration and the economy more widely
and possibly looking at brexit and so on
they're talking about the future of
European integration and where the whole
thing the whole ship should eventually
your sail towards you know what about
online Merkel's a position wrapping it
up how strong is the CDU and the
governing coalition right now after the
drubbing they took you know could we see
new elections in Germany or or what are
we looking at moving forward yeah well
there's several things I think I I think
new elections early elections are
unlikely because these two government
parties have done so poorly they're
unlikely to say let's go and ask the
voters to give us another bad result
anytime soon
they can let the thing run on as far as
Angela Merkel is concerned she's kind of
made herself a little bit of relevant in
this campaign not appearing really very
much and but now today after a bad
result she's trying to take some of the
heat off the new party leader and a
great cramp Karen Bao who has only been
in in the post for six months people are
saying well this was her first electoral
test and she's failed it Angela Merkel
saying no well maybe it was mistakes
that I made the party as a whole saying
well we haven't appeal to young voters
we haven't got on top of the social
media and the sort of the digital media
that two young people are attracted to
and where they get some of their
information from so there's a lot of
soul-searching going on today but I
think the in the in the smoke-filled
rooms or the smokeless rooms in the
background people will be
really studying these results and
wondering how they can do better next
time okay and they'll be looking at
where all those young voters went they
went to the greens especially Simon
young thanks for now and we'll have live
coverage of the German greens party
press conference that's following their
success in the European elections that's
coming up later in this program first
though the far-right have made strong
gains in France pushing president macros
party into second place so let's go down
to Paris where a correspondent Monday
Walsh house is standing by for a second
morning Emanuel marine lepen National
Rally beating McCombs party but only by
a small margin according to the latest
results here now what does that tell us
about the strength of the populist in
France right now
well it definitely tells us that the
winning party yesterday was marine lepen
Hassan Rahman Arsenal National Rally
like he said it's only by a small margin
that they beat Emmanuel macron la
république Omar the National Rally won
by 23.3 percent so that's only one point
more than macros party it shows that
their strategy their campaign strategy
paid off over the political the rest of
the political landscape here in France
all the parties showed this sanction you
can see that this no longer a coherent
Left Party in France the Socialist Party
no longer attracts voters neither the
false assume is the party of jean-luc
mélenchon and it simply shows that the
National Rally managed to maintain some
coherence for the voters which turned
their backs to traditional party to
choose the far-right are the first
political forces in France you know what
does this result mean for a president
micron can he continue governing as he
has up until now in the future moving
forward well the press the pressure was
already on when the yellow vest crisis
started it had they on everything he had
been elected in fact he had been elected
by 60% of the French people but more as
a reaction against the far-right the
far-right at the national election the
presidential election fed up
40 percent that's a lot of support
within the French population so the
pressure was on for Emmanuel macron from
the beginning it has only excel
accentuated ever since it has only
increased with the yellow vests crisis
so in inner circles we heard that a
Prime Minister affiliate had said to his
Minister during the last counts you that
he would be here next week but he wasn't
sure about his ministers so maybe he hit
other ministers about the rest of his
government so maybe we will see some
changes in the coming weeks following
that election because of in any case
this really weakens Emmanuel macron a
bit further in the French opinion okay
so we have a weakened president we have
a strong National Rally
what is marine lepen going to do now are
the goals going to be to change how
things get done in Brussels or is the
main priority going to be capitalizing
on the political gains domestically in
France they will capitalize on that
political gain it gives my Independence
Party more legitimacy also on a European
level and she called for a union or the
European far right now that's something
that many analysts say they don't see
likely happening because of the diverse
opinions within the far-right in Europe
but yesterday evening Manila can
certainly say to her spokesperson for
the National Rally Jordan Barajas only
twenty to twenty three-year-old years
old and he said this this victory opens
the way for the formation of a powerful
group in the Europe European Parliament
so we see that a national rally will
endeavor to implement all the changes
they want to implement from within and
no longer will try to destroy the
European Parliament from without from
outside of it okay and that is certainly
a position that material Sylvanian
italy's interested in as well so we'll
see those two no doubt working together
in that area among evil shots for now in
Paris thanks so very much